[Music]
joining me today is a Swedish comedian a
podcaster and a youtuber Aron flam
welcome to the Reuben report thank you
so much i'll grudgingly accept the last
description of being a youtuber but
thank you I've come around on the
youtuber thing people are saying oh
you're a youtuber you know the phrase
you're a youtuber and that seemed it
either seemed mildly offensive or
childish or it's like you're a kid with
a webcam or something like that but I've
sort of embraced it at this point are
you are you able to embrace this you're
so much more than the kid with a webcam
yes we have four cameras here we're
doing I think have you been able to
embrace that concept I think I'm coming
around to it as well because by now I'm
publishing all my comedy specials on
YouTube directly had it not been for
YouTube I would not have known who you
are and I got a burst of emails from
your fans saying check this guy out and
then I got an email from Tina sana da
Jie who I've had on the show yes and
people said check this guy out and I
went to YouTube so we really have to
thank YouTube for well yes and I also I
discovered you this Christmas
while I was curating the at Sweden
account on Twitter and that have that
you you were the one that put me on the
hate list no no I'm surprised I actually
when I got nominated I was like this
must be a mistake
and they were like he wants to be
anonymous and I was like yeah that makes
sense so for the people that don't know
what you're talking about there was a
list it's a little unclear to me exactly
what happened but this is just in the
last couple weeks
there was this list curated by was it
the official Sweden Twitter account
Sweden has an official Twitter account
right and you anyone can not only
sweetie can be nominated to handle the
account for a week that you're supposed
to be able to get free reigns to do
whatever you want right and this has
gotten them into some high water before
yes it has and so I was nominated for
last Christmas because I'm probably the
only public Jew in Sweden who doesn't
celebrate Christmas so they were like no
one's gonna watch it anyway yeah and
they gave it to me yeah and then a few
months later they gave it to some lefty
who has compiled a huge safeSpace list
with like 12,000 or so names and your
name is on it yeah and this list was
well the description of the list was
right-wing Nazi extremists that you call
for violence or stuff like that and your
name is on the list sir so you're
apparently why right-wing extremists yes
big all right neo-nazi over here I saw
people started tweeting me the list then
I get a call from my mom saying are you
banned from sweden it's like what up
what planet are we on there's no I don't
worry about it I was actually ashamed to
find that my name was not on the list
yeah you're in Sweden yes I know I know
but I think it's because the Swede the
Swedish normal way of handling conflict
is by ignoring it so we're well we're
gonna get to a lot of that but even that
concept right there that Sweden does
allow this but a citizen is allowed to
control it's it's just at Sweden right
is the official yeah yes but it it's
allowed to control the Twitter handle I
mean what are their country in the world
would do this no other country and I
think in their own minds it was a like a
we're so Pro democracy that we let
anyone handle but then just a few months
in they started with censoring you know
they started with rules of conduct for
the Swedish I didn't really care about
those when I handled the account but
yeah then again it was Christmas and no
one stopped me did you feel some sort of
great sense of power when you had that
account I mean you could have started
some sort of war or an international but
I was lucky unfortunately no nothing no
you couldn't say you know we're invading
Switzerland well I hinted about Finland
might you know becoming part of Sweden
again yeah yeah and Norway as well and
didn't get an official response from the
at Finland no no there I don't think
they have an at Finland I don't know we
don't even have that no I don't I don't
think they do
very bizarre all right Swedish comedian
something about that even that phrase
sort of sounds funny to me you don't
think we don't think of at least in
America we don't think of Sweden having
like a great rich history of comedy so
tell me a little bit about growing up in
Sweden what leads a Swedish kid to
become a comedian well outside ership is
not a correct word I think I think
that's a word yeah he's close enough to
a word well I grew up in
social-democratic Sweden my father being
a social democrat like no Swedes
I just never felt home in the
collectivist environment there and
always saw things a bit from the outside
I suppose I'm also Jewish so that might
have helped if helped is really the
right word in that outsider yeah thing
and then I wanted to be a writer and
most publications didn't want to take in
my writings and after a while I realized
well all I seem to be writing is jokes
even though I was a very pretentious kid
so I thought of it as poetry yeah so and
then I tried stand-up and I was hooked
yeah is there a vibrant stand-up scene
well it's coming around because of
YouTube and it the internet mostly kids
now grow up watching American and
British comedy and that has really
helped Swedes like to think of
themselves as a country that has a
British sense of humor but it really
does not it's more force and slapstick
yeah yeah so you mentioned this
collectivist vers individualist concept
now obviously I talk about that here
what's it really like growing up in that
like when you were seeing it as a kid
and say and as you said your dad was a
Democratic Socialist you were part of
this society that was collectivist what
does that really mean when you're
where's your nerd well according to a
lot of the stuff I have around here yes
so you have been accused of it once or
twice yes so you're probably familiar
with the Star Trek Ian lure of the Borg
a much more Star Wars
okay sure and so am i yeah but the Borg
is an alien species and Star Trek that
it's a collective consciousness and they
go to Planet from planet to planet and
sort of incorporate the indigenous
species into their own consciousness
erasing all traces of individuality that
is what it's like today so what is that
what does that mean though like so all
right so you're now let's say you're
you're in middle school and you have a
different political thought is it just
is it just shunned immediately like
first people perceive you as weird
Swedes are really afraid of conflict so
they they really they're more passive
aggressive than aggressive and I'm very
aggressive aggressive so it doesn't
really mesh well and then
Sweden has as a mechanism for social
cohesion is the freezing out so that you
get frozen out or you become a social
pariah something like that ignored yeah
do you sense the counter movement to
this that you're obviously probably on
there and that T knows part of and
several other people do you sense it
growing because I get a ton of email
from Sweden I'd say probably like a
fifth of my email or so maybe a little
bit less if just broken down by country
is Sweden which you know per capita is
crazy
well I sense it growing but I fear it
might be too little too late and that it
that Sweden is too socialist and has
been too socialist for too long
culturally and socially socialist
economically not so much because the
counter movement in Sweden right now
what you would term Lee alright
the Swedish Democrats is basically
because conservative just means that you
want to preserve what were has been so
conservative in Sweden means you want to
be the social democratic between 1950
and 1970 so what you have is a national
social nationalist socialist movement
except maybe not Jew hatred this time
right yes so but so it's not Jew hatred
but it's now caught up in in immigrants
and migrants and there is a it's really
hard to tell the difference between
genuine critique of Islam and prejudice
against Muslims yeah so that's all a big
mess right now yeah so when I discuss
some of this stuff with Tino and we'll
put the link in the description below so
that people can watch the the interview
a lot of what we talked about was sort
of the difference between religion and
culture and also that Sweden has a
strong state where it's giving a lot to
people which then actually enforces a
ghettoization of all that where do you
where do you fall on this well I don't
agree with Tino completely but the way I
see it Sweden is a socialist democratic
country really it's a corporate to this
country which means Sweden unlike most
European countries never had a
revolution they'd work workers movement
just sat down with the oligarchs they
shook hand and they were like we're
going to divide this up don't have high
taxation and Hugh
transfera love money and so what they
have is the unions have a lot of power
and we have something called the
collective agreement which means you
don't individually negotiate for your
salary but the union will negotiate for
you and this creates sort of a
segregated society when you bring in a
lot of immigrants because they don't get
into the system it's not only refugees
it's first and second-generation
immigrants nothing don't get into the
system so they get left outside of the
system which creates this apartheid like
State mm-hmm I had a we did a fan show a
couple weeks ago where I interviewed 20
people from all over the world and one
of the people that I interviewed was an
18 year old girl in Sweden who was born
in Syria I think she came when she was
maybe one or even less than one and she
was saying to me that she really only
experiences racism from the left sort of
the racism of low expectations that they
always want to sort of help her or she
should think this way yeah or any of
that safety do you see that absolutely
because that's what their social you
have to remember Sweden was voluntarily
socially democratic for only almost
uninterruptedly
eight years that means the entire
population voted for the same party for
80 years yeah
and part of the socialist dogma if you
like is that it's not your own fault
you're a victim of circumstance and so
well everyone becomes a victim first
it's the workers movement I mean if you
were born in England maybe you'd flaunt
your nobility if you were born into a
noble family but in Sweden Swedes
usually say well a middle-class now but
I come from working-class as if though
the fact that your ancestors were poor
and uneducated is something great right
and we see that now all over the left in
almost every country right yes yeah and
as as you say eating itself yeah it is
eating itself at at a very high level
right now but I should pause for a
second because I just realized you were
sitting in an Ikea chair oh really
yeah so you I think are the first Swede
that I've had on the show in studio and
you're sitting
how do people feel about IKEA this is it
we're gonna drop you yeah
oh I think we love I mean is it B is it
the like pinnacle of its where you go or
you buy furniture that you're gonna have
for 10 years until your kids grow up
there you can throw it out and hopefully
by that time you've inherited something
nice from your dead parents yeah it's
what I've always had a love/hate thing
with IKEA because I for most of my life
I didn't have a lot of money or and
lived in small apartments and things so
I would always get everything at IKEA
and then about 2 years ago I was on Joe
Rogan's show and I said I'll know I'm a
success when at least half of my stuff I
think is not IKEA for now I've basically
shifted out of Ikea but we just opened
the world's largest have you been there
no no bank while you're in town it's the
world's largest IKEA yes but it's also a
variance to go to Ikea any day of the
week I love it I've come to love it I
don't I can't explain why even if I
don't get anything and I just get
Swedish meatballs for some reason I love
IKEA oh really well I think if you want
to break up with your partner but don't
know how to do it bring them to Ikea on
a Saturday and it's done yeah and very
quickly you don't see P you can really
look through somebody yeah when you're
at IKEA is there anything about the IKEA
that model of sort of cheap stuff but
that's sort of functional but you have
to do something to put it together does
that have something to do with some of
this Democratic Socialist stuff am I
going on real leap there is there
something about is that that concept no
I don't think you're entirely wrong
because you have to understand Sweden
was a very collectivist what was it we
actually have a word for it in Swedish
consensus culture even before socialism
and then socialism came in and I think
those two ideas the culture of socialism
and the culture of Sweden married very
well perfectly actually and then so we
had PC before you had PC we just call it
consensus culture and consensus culture
is that you everyone has to agree you
sacrifice diversity for unity so have
there been political leaders even though
you've had 80 years of you know sort of
one type of rule
have there been political leaders even
in the last 20 years that really were
starting to go guys something's not
right here I mean has there been
any movement no really I think the last
conservative I mean not the last
conservative the first Conservative
government really of my life back in the
90s they were voted in when we had a
huge economic crisis so they couldn't
really do much and I think most of the
conservative parties or right-wing
parties or whatever you like to call
them they have resigned to the idea of
the welfare state and so all the parties
we have in our Parliament sign off from
the welfare state and I think 90% of the
ethnically Swedish population wants the
welfare state and that is why I think
even though you might see small rise in
libertarians in Sweden they will not out
compete the conservative socialists yeah
do you think the average person in
Sweden realizes that more people are
looking to Sweden now as as sort of the
precursor of what's happening with
leftism all over the world like even a
couple months back Trump made a sort of
off the hand comment about Sweden and
then suddenly everybody started talking
about soon and then it was very hard to
people started asking me because we've
talked about it a bit here on what do
you think's really going on there and
it's very hard to figure out at least
from the media that we get well I really
hope that the rest of the Western world
at least looks to Sweden and takes it as
a warning example and don't make our
mistakes Swedes have this idea that they
got rich by being a peace-loving nation
I mean Swedes termed themselves and
tried to get the world to see them as a
moral superpower not a real superpower
just a moral superpower but this is
hypocrisy because Sweden didn't get to
be one of the richest countries in the
world through socialism it got to be one
of the richest countries in the world by
staying out of two world wars and then
selling arms to both sides but I guess
peace-loving sounds better than war so
and you can't call yourself a
hypocritical state because then you
would be admitting to being a hypocrite
thus not being a hypocrite so moral
superpower is what we're going with
is that discussion ever had in Sweden I
suspect not just the the concept that we
were selling things to both sides and
thought of as a war country really
no I don't think we'd talk about it I
talk about it in my stand-up and have
been for 10 years but the rest of the
country no we're still a peace-loving
moral superpower yeah so when you when
you talk about this stuff in stand up
stand up in a way when you're in a room
with that people it can be very
collectivist you know when people start
laughing then other people start
laughing if people go uh then other
people do that yeah how have you been
able to break through some of that well
it's been really really hard I mean my
first steps into political comedy came
with our weed lady's legislation because
we have draconian marijuana laws yeah
sorry the laws yeah
so I started joking about smoking weed
and for the first like five to seven
years the entire room would fall silent
and like before I went into that
material a joke about pedophilia and you
know maybe rape or whatever and they
just laugh and then you go into witness
completely silent so and that started
turning around like five years ago
something like that and then I started
talking about feminism and the same
thing so there are cultural specific
taboos in Sweden and I think that they
have been theirs they're permeating the
entire society and the culture to such
an extent that you can't really talk
about this subject talk about these
subjects without causing offence yeah
but you like causing event yes I do
yeah where does that come from do you
think is that that's that outside Irish
thing that you mentioned earlier maybe
at heart I think I might be a contrarian
so if people tell me that I can't cause
offence I sort of had to so when you
decided to start putting videos on
YouTube now you were gonna get this and
doing a podcast you know you were gonna
get this stuff outside the small borders
of your country no actually I just
wanted to wake up Swedes to begin with I
started out doing political satire in
Sweden and after a while I got some type
of low-budget Daily Show thing going on
government television state television
which is not like NPR is here it's huge
state television used to be the only
television
and I was censored so much for three
seasons that I really really got fed up
with it yeah you know how did they even
give you a show in the first place if
you're a mr. individual they're their
team collective it was a mistake on
their part and also I had a friend who's
really in with Swedish television but he
had just had a small child he was burnt
out but had signed a deal for content so
he needed content I had a pilot the
pilot was super boring and about the
federal reserve so they thought well if
he's just going to do about Federal
Reserve and mechanism of democracy
doesn't matter and just give him a show
yeah little did they know yes and then I
pushed as hard as I could for three
seasons but then I thought I'm gonna
burn out I don't want to do this anymore
yeah so if we were to go to Sweden right
now and I hop on the plane back to
Sweden with you and you're walking down
the street and people see you they go
that the guy that's saying all that [ __ ]
that we shouldn't be saying mm maybe I
don't know in that case it would be
behind my back yes I'm not confronted a
lot yes maybe on Twitter but right
silence can be hard enough to bear trust
me yeah you know I know I'm sure you can
so let's just circle back to some of the
immigration stuff for a second so Sweden
basically has led in a lot of immigrants
migrants refugees whatever you want to
call them it's a mix of all of those
things there's been this sense that the
integration hasn't gone that well partly
partly because the government gave these
people so much there isn't a reason to
sort of integrate into society have you
had any experience with the with the
migrant or refugee community well yes I
have because I have colleagues who are
first and second generation and I grew
up in a suburb outside of Sweden who you
would part of it you could call a
Swedish ghetto
not an American ghetto by any any
measurement you'd use but so it's quite
a quaint ghetto all right so what is
that what does that actually mean
like that they have a heart especially
young men have a very hard time finding
job and getting into the system and you
really have to be into the system it's
like lacking credit in the United States
so you'd be pretty much out of it right
so and so we've been letting in a lot of
immigrants for the last thirty years and
most of these immigrants are not
European and they have a very different
culture and I don't think that the
second generation don't want to get into
the labor force I think they do but they
can't because even if even if I mean
most of the second generation immigrants
I know they don't see subsidies as right
like most Swedes do they Swedes are so
born into it that they considered all
the subsidies their birthright they
don't question them at all so they have
no incentive to work really but they get
into the system and then they work
anyway right and the second generation
would like to get into the system but
they can't because of the union laws
menu so with the best way to be get rid
of some of the subsidies because then
things would start correcting themselves
it might be a little bumpy on the way
but that perhaps that would be I don't
really see that possibility because I
think Swedes have been insulated for too
long to be able to make that leap by now
I'm doing this only so that by the end
of my life I can pretty much say I told
you so yeah that's right right is it who
else is doing it right now I mean we
sort of touched on this but I mean is
there a party right now that really is
pushing back on this well the Swedish
Democrats have some sort of agenda when
it comes to immigration but for the rest
of the political system they don't want
to change anything really they want the
unions to be where they have always been
and they want what we call the Swedish
model to persist yeah so it will so we
sort of see that consistently that if we
can't have these conversations that you
guys are obviously grappling with yeah
but then you're only going to be left
with sort of two alternatives one that
duck you know puts their head in the
sand and the other one that maybe is is
more based in sand
a phobia and that kind of thing could be
I mean the leadership I think definitely
is yeah I don't know enough about the
party this specific general theme there
yeah I think the leadership is yeah but
by now they're they're passing 20% it's
not racists anymore it's people
disenfranchised enfranchise and
disillusioned by the existing political
system
[Music]
you